Traduttore: Paola Barbazza
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
(Musica di sottofondo)
Hey, c'mon!
Buongiorno!
Questa sì che è un'energia wonder!
Wow! "Wahaha" è anche il mantra
della felicità.
Quando voi siete così entusiasti,
quando noi siamo davvero felici,
le nostre trilioni di cellule
che compongono i nostri corpi umani,
i templi della nostra anima,
davvero esultano e sprigioniamo
benessere ovunque.
Oggi sono qui per parlarvi
di un qualcosa
di veramente straordinario
per le nostre vite umane.
Sono qui per parlarvi di HAPPY GENETICA.
Oltre vent'anni fa, quando ero ancora
un giovane ragazzo, accadde
un qualche cosa di veramente
molto difficile nella mia vita:
mio babbo si ammalò
di una grave malattia
e le sue ultime parole,
prima di lasciare il suo corpo,
furono: "Sii sempre felice".
Certo, non è assolutamente facile
per una persona che perde
un proprio caro essere felici.
Ma devo dirvi che è stato
grazie a quell'esperienza,
così traumatica
e così dolorosa, che mi ha dato
la possibilità di ricercare davvero
quale fosse il senso della felicità,
o anche l'utilità dell'essere felice.
Per questo motivo, mi addentrai
nel mondo della meditazione,
dello yoga e praticai mindfulness.
Addirittura, con la mia famiglia decisi
di trasferirmi nella mia amata India,
nel centro-sud dell'India, a Puttaparthi.
Provavo a meditare,
provavo ad essere sereno,
calmo, in pace con me stesso,
ma la felicità non la sentivo
mai dentro di me.
Un giorno, non per caso,
ma per serendipità,
feci una scoperta davvero straordinaria:
scoprì il potere terapeutico della risata.
Ogni giorno al mattino, alle 4:30,
oltre a meditare, praticavo
in solitudine la risata incondizionata.
Più ridevo,
più le mie cellule ridevano con me,
più ridevo,
più il mio atteggiamento mentale cambiava.
Come disse il grande William James:
"Ogni essere umano
ha un grande potenziale:
quello di trasformare la propria vita,
cambiando il proprio atteggiamento
mentale, cambiando le proprie abitudini".
Non solo continuai a ridere da solo,
ma portai la terapia della risata
perfino negli orfanotrofi,
negli ospedali, nelle aziende,
nei villaggi sperduti del sud dell'India.
Cosa osservai?
Il cambiamento radicale nella vita,
nei volti delle persone che empaticamente
sorridevano assieme a me.
C'è una branca della scienza direi WONDER,
straordinaria che studia
quanto le circostanze esterne
possano cambiare la nostra genetica.
Vi sto parlando di epigenetica.
Il nostro codice epigenetico
è molto importante
perché è quello che ci permette
di sopravvivere, di relazionarci
con l'ambiente nel quale noi viviamo.
Sappiamo ad esempio
che la dieta alimentare influisce
nella nostra genetica, ma anche
le nostre emozioni.
Oggi, più che mai,
siamo troppo stressati.
Questo danneggia, irrimediabilmente,
la nostra salute, il nostro benessere.
Non ce lo possiamo permettere
perché essere felici
è una grande responsabilità sociale.
Attraverso gli studi approfonditi
dell'epigenetica, ho potuto osservare
come le nostre emozioni hanno
davvero il potere di cambiare,
non solo il nostro mindset,
ma addirittura la qualità
delle nostre vite.
Dall'epigenetica alla HAPPY GENETICA.
Che cos'è la HAPPY GENETICA ?
Sono tutte quelle abitudini felici
che noi, giorno dopo giorno,
dovremmo implementare nella nostra vita,
quelle abitudini che ti permettono
di percepire questa energia
straordinaria, curativa, terapeutica:
l'energia della felicità.
Meditare, ridere
e profondo rilassamento sono alcune
delle basi straordinarie
che fondono la HAPPY GENETICA.
Come sicuramente saprete,
quando noi ridiamo, naturalmente,
abbiamo il potere di trasformare
la nostra giornata,
ma anche la giornata
di chi vive accanto a noi.
Come ci ricorda la scienza,
quando noi ridiamo,
il nostro corpo, alcune parti
del nostro corpo,
il cervello, sprigionano
queste sostanze chimiche,
la chimica della felicità.
Quando tu ridi scateni nel tuo corpo
una dose di sana felicità.
D.O.S.E. è l'acronimo
che sta per dopamina, ossitocina,
serotonina ed endorfine.
Vi rendete conto ?
Quando ci lasciamo ridere,
il nostro corpo gioisce
grazie a questa chimica
e la risata ha questa virtù terapeutica,
addirittura di trasmutare
il tuo codice epigenetico.
Vi ricordate quando è stata l'ultima
volta in cui avete riso ?
In qualche ambito lavorativo ?
In famiglia ?
Beh, naturalmente sono stato invitato
qui come speaker,
per aiutarvi a lasciarvi ridere.
Vi va di farlo insieme a me?
Ok, un semplice esercizio.
Mi raccomando,
fatemi fare bella figura.
Braccia in avanti,
portiamo le braccia verso di noi
e inspiriamo, trattieni
e fuori la risata
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
Se non vi viene da ridere
è perché state pensando a vostra suocera.
Lasciatevi ridere con il mantra
della felicità: "Wahaha".
Non preoccupatevi,
il corpo, dicono gli scienziati,
non è in grado di riconoscere
quando una risata è spontanea
o quando è spintanea.
Pertanto, ridiamo che è meglio.
Portiamo le mani davanti a noi,
tratteniamo il fiato e ridiamo.
Ah ah ah ah ah ah
Bravissimi.
Ultima volta.
Inspiriamo, tratteniamo
e adesso ridiamo.
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
E adesso fai un applauso
al tuo sorriso e alla tua risata.
C'mon!
(Applausi)
Certo, la scienza afferma
che per sprigionare questa dose
di sana chimica della felicità
dovremmo ridere addirittura
per 15 minuti.
Questa è la mia missione:
aiutare le persone a rilasciare
questa straordinaria energia.
Ma una delle basi fondamentali
della HAPPY GENETICA,
e questa è una notizia
molto importante,
in grado di cambiare
la nostra struttura genetica,
è soprattutto quando noi
intercettiamo quelle emozioni positive
che ci onorano,
di essere degli esseri umani.
Voglio fare un esperimento qui con voi,
se vi va.
Vi chiedo di chiudere un attimo gli occhi.
E mentre continuo a parlare,
vi chiedo di portare la vostra attenzione
al centro del petto, quello
che viene definito il chakra del cuore.
Quando noi ridiamo,
migliora la nostra salute,
si abbassa lo stress,
soprattutto diamo la possibilità
alle nostre emozioni trattenute
di essere rilasciate.
Questo ci permette davvero
di vivere una vita degna
di essere vissuta.
Ora che la vostra attenzione è lì,
al centro del petto,
vi chiedo di iniziare a percepire,
con la forza della vostra immaginazione,
questi raggi di luce dorata,
iniziate a percepire
questa energia straordinaria
e iniziate a sviluppare
questo senso di profonda gratitudine
per ogni tua singola cellula,
trilioni di cellule che compongono
il tuo corpo umano.
Sviluppate gratitudine
per tutti gli organi
che vi permettono di vivere
questa vita straordinaria.
Percepite questi raggi di luce dorata
e inizia a donare, attraverso
la tua gratitudine,
questa sensazione di amore,
di pace, a tutte le persone
che amate.
Immaginate di avvolgerle,
di abbracciare i vostri cari.
Donate gratitudine
per essere presenti nella vostra vita,
per rendere la vostra vita
così preziosa.
Continuate ad alimentare
questa energia.
Immaginate ora di avvolgere
anche quei cari amici, amiche,
ma anche i colleghi di lavoro.
Permettete a questa energia straordinaria
di farvi percepire
il senso di appartenenza,
unità nella diversità.
Ora vi chiedo di alimentare
questi raggi luminosi,
pieni di energia positiva,
e dona questa energia,
soprattutto a quelle menti malate
che sono presenti sul pianeta Terra.
Permettete a questa energia straordinaria
di trasformare la loro energia,
di farli sentire parte
di questa grande famiglia,
che è l'umanità.
E ancora vi chiedo ora
di avvolgere
in questa energia straordinaria
il pianeta Terra, Pachamama, Gaia,
che ti permette di realizzare
la tua vita, i tuoi sogni,
di sperimentare ciò che voi siete.
Percepite questo meraviglioso senso
di appartenenza,
unità nella diversità.
Ora vi chiedo di appoggiare,
delicatamente,
le mani al centro del petto,
il chakra del cuore.
Ora vi chiedo di sperimentare
profonda gratitudine
a una persona davvero WONDER,
meravigliosa, senza la quale,
tutto questo
non potrebbe essere sperimentato.
Questa persona, degna di essere amata,
SEI TU.
Ora, delicatamente, aprite gli occhi
e donatevi quell'applauso
che nessuno mai vi ha donato,
e fatelo ora, con voi stessi.
"Wahaha"
La vita è una questione di scelte,
e sapere scegliere è catturare
le migliori opportunità.
La felicità è una scelta.
E noi oggi siamo tremendamente
fortunati
perché possiamo scegliere
di vivere,
grazie alle abitudini felici
e di sperimentare il meglio
nelle nostre vite.
La tua vita dipende unicamente
dalle tue scelte.
Quali sono le scelte migliori ?
Sono quelle scelte che impattano
con il tuo benessere fisico,
mentale, emozionale, spirituale.
Hai scelto bene tutte le volte
che metti a disposizione la tua vita
al servizio degli altri,
della collettività,
delle persone
che ogni giorni incontri
su questo straordinario pianeta Terra.
Se sei qui, se hai ricevuto
questo dono straordinario
della vita, sei qui per dare
il tuo migliore contributo.
L'espressione della felicità,
l'espressione della gioia,
è il nostro vero DNA.
Siamo tutti qui per riconoscerlo
perché oggi, più che mai,
anziché cercare cittadini esemplari,
la nostra grande opportunità
è di essere quell'esempio.
L'esempio è quello di donare,
incondizionatamente, il nostro amore,
ovunque, a chiunque,
attraverso il nostro sorriso,
attraverso la nostra
straordinaria risata.
Se voi davvero siete felici,
fatelo sentire alle vostre cellule.
Soprattutto quando tornate a casa
abbracciate i vostri cari,
e dite loro: "Ti sono grato
per tutta la vita,
il mio sorriso è per te".
"Wahaha"
(Applausi)